今 前の方から 世間の評価ということに関してなんですけれども
世間の評価ということに関してなんですけれども
例えば芸能人たちなんかは
生きてる時は人気があっても
死んでしまうとほとんど忘れられてしまうので
それだけのことだと思っておりましたけれども
わからないのは 芸術家で生きてる時は全然画家なんか全く評価されずに
死んでからすごく絵の位置がつくとか
人気が出ている芸術家なんですが
それに関してはどういう考え方ですか
まあ大体生きてる場合はね
あんまり評価されなかったっていうことは
嫌われているということなんですね
だから嫌われているんだから
作品も見ようとしないんですね
人が死んでしまっちゃったんだから
どうでもいいんですね
それで作品を評価するんですよ
だから情けないんですよ
だから世間の評価っていうのはそんなもんですよ
気にする必要はないんです
素晴らしい作品を作っても
人のこと嫌いんだったら
その人の作品は捨てちゃうんです
恐ろしいんですよ そこでもう気に入らない人が死んでしまってからは堂々と評価する
それでも食べ物もなくて
もうほとんどもう飢えている状態で生活して
もう病気になって死んでしまって
それから作品は 3000万円とかね
そうしたら商売やってるんです
世界が 恐ろしいんじゃないんですかね
だから  それがやっぱり
芸術家はね  芸術家にも頑固なところありますからね
そこで評価されなくなっちゃいますよ
芸術家はあんまりにも自分のことばっかし気にする
すごいわがままでしょ
そこで引っかかっちゃうんですよ
だから絵を描きながら
これでいい これはどう？とかね
だから子供でもこれはおじいちゃん
ちょっとかっこ悪い ああ
そうですかね やっぱりこのじじいにはね
これしか描けませんだからねとかね
そんな感じのものだったらね
もうみんなに嫌われませんね
そうなってくると まあ生きてる間で作品は評価されます
大体人格者の場合は評価されますよ
生きてる間では  そういうところです
後ろの方でどうぞ あの 4つの施しとヴィパッサナーの違い
ん？施しとヴィパッサナーの違いが
ああ あの施しの場合は大体あのものとものになりますしね
それだっていうのはどちらかというとアドバイス的なものなんですね
アドバイス的な 仏教でアッタチャリアっていうのは
やっぱり道徳的なところになりますから
えーと 例えば助けてあげることと良いアドバイスをすることというふうに区別してみればね
それかその 4つの項と前半でおっしゃったあの八正道かなというところ
はいはい  あまり重ならない
重ならないようですが
生徒が重なってます 重なってないものもあるんですけど
えっ？ 6つと 7つが どういう関係？大借手の 7項目と 4つの項目が重なってないけれど
どういう関係があるのか
ああ それはあのアプローチの違いなんですよ
大食点がブッダじゃないし
悟ってもないし 大食点がこの昔
この七つの福士をやっていたんですね
だから本人の専門なんですね
その 7つは別々にやっただけのことで
お釈迦様が真理というところで
科学的なアプローチで見たら 4つだよと
だから同じことだと思いますよ
ちょこちょこっと見ると
まあ具体的にあの両親を養うとかもあるだけの話で
両親を養うこともある面で同地でもあるし
平等でもあるし それから施しにも入るし
もう両親にもアッタチャリアね
あの なんて言いますか
有意義な生き方 例えば両親に
あの まあもうもうそろそろもうお年だから
もう俗世間のことを忘れて心清らかにしてくださいとか
一生懸命協力するんだから
もう瞑想したり 無駄なことを学んだりしてくださいとかね
そういう風にいい方向へ押すことも
親孝行でもありながらアッタチャリアでもあります
論理的に論法に基づいて
良性の安らぎとか霊の人々を尊重するっていうのも論理的に法に則っている
でしょう だってそういう人々が我々を育てるんだからね
じゃあ噂をしないとかっていうことにも
やっぱりそれは噂 大食店の項目でしょ
噂するっていうことは
もうなんか人の悪口言いふらすことだから役に立たんでしょ
だからアッタチャリアの反対なんですよ
アナッタチャリアなんです
あの人こんなことやったんだよ
こんな人こんなことやったんだよという噂で
噂の場合は明らかに悪いこと
噂なんですよ 人の良いこと言うことは噂じゃないんです
これ 噂の定義をよく覚えた方がいいんです
例えば人の欠点をその人がないところで言いふらす
それが悪行為なんです
人の良いことをどこで言いふらしたってもいいんです
それは善行為なんです
それで人の悪いことをあちこち言いふらすと
これアッタチャリアになりません
有益な生き方になりません
そういうことだから それはもう避けましょうということですね
はい  他の方はい はい どうぞ
今日のお話は 人間は外側ではなくて中身が大事だという極めて単純
しかし 我々がなかなか取らない見方を教えていただいて
大変心に響きました 私たちは商業主義の中に生きていて
人は見かけが 9割とかいう本も出ましたね
若さと美しさの方が価値があるのではないかと思ってしまう穴に落ち込んでいて
ありがたいお話だったと思います
私の質問はちょっと離れるんですが
経典にもよくありますし
今日のお話にも出てきました
神々というのは一体どういう存在でしょうか
私は見たことも聞いたこともありませんが
想像上のものなのでしょうか
これは私に聞いたっても意味まあ
経典にあるんだからね
あの まあ仏教初期経典ではね
ただもう普通人間と同じく仲間で
そっちを聞いたり話したりしていたみたいで
神々っていうのは まあわからないと思ったっても
別に問題はありません
あの まあ人間 生命たくさんいますよ
あらゆる次元に だからこの動物と我々だけ生命と仏教は見てないんです
この肉体 細胞を持っているだけで生命と仏教は思ってないんです
だから科学 生物学の世界では
あのアミノ酸にできている細胞があれば生命ということになるでしょ
それはあくまでも物理学なんですね
仏教の生命というのは心ですね
心があれば生命ということで
だから心が 例えばこのペットボトルに宿ったら
もう生命なんですよ もうどうしようもないんです
そういうわけで 心っていうエネルギーはいろんなところで
いろんな次元にあります
そこは９つの次元 仏教でかかってます
語ってます もうわからないのは別に気にすることはありません
それはもうかなりね 人間にわからないところもいっぱいあります
ただ 文学的に取ったっても構いません
もう普通 我々の文化的に見れば
神っていうのは偉くてね
人間が拝んでお願い事をする存在であると
普通の 神話的に理解しても意味は通じます
そういうみんなありがたがってる神が俺私のことをありがたがっているんだよっていう話なんです
うん  もう大丈夫です はい
ありがとうございます
あの 懺と喜のことなんですけれども
あの懺は悪いことをすることを恥じる
はい 喜は悪いことをすることを恐れるという意味なんですけれども
あの 例えばですね あの人のやったことを
さも自分がやったことのようにやってしまった時にですね
要するにその恥ずかしいという気持ちが懺ということで
それでそのやったことに対して
人から批判 攻撃を受けることを恐れるっていうのが喜というような受け取り方でよろしいですか
これが違うんじゃないかなと思いますよ
自分が悪いことをしたならば
人が批判するのは当然でしょ
人の批判を受けることは気じゃないんです
人の批判 堂々と受けた方がいいんです
しょうがない 私は悪いことしまったからと
その人が勇気を持って聞くんです
逃げ回ると 自分の悪行為を隠そうとしているんですね
で 喜っていうのは悪いことをすること自体が怖いということで
もう怖くて体が動かないんだと
で 自分が謝って悪いことをしたと言いならば
堂々とすいませんでしたと
私が間違えましたと 非難でも侮辱でも
どうぞ思い存分やってくださいと
いうふうに そこで勇気を持つんです
例えば友達に言われたあなたのことを散々言われてるでしょうと
新聞でもいっぱい書かれてるでしょうという
だってしょうがないでしょうと
私はそんなをやっちゃったんだからね
という態度は勇気なんですよ
だからその時逃げ回ることは気に入りません
罪をごまかすことになるんです
罪をごまかすことも罪なんです
仏教では罪を犯す人間
完璧じゃないんだから
いくら懺悔があっても失敗はしますよ
ですから 失敗する可能性はあります
しかし ごまかすなよと
だから 自分の過ちを認める勇気っていうのはすごい立派なものなんですよ
認めたら一発で解決します
本人堂々と認めているんだから
新聞にももう書くことなくなっちゃうんです
逃げ回るともう次から次へと書くんです
そういうことで この悪
自分の失敗を認めることっていうのは
その問題はものすごく早く処理することなんです
できるだけ大きくなる前に処理した方がいいんです
だから火はマッチ棒にある間で消した方がいいんです
それはもう火事になるまでは待ってはいけませんということで
マッチ棒に火を付けたところで
どんどん広げて家丸ごと焼ける
もう延焼 燃焼する可能性もあるんですからね
そこで火は危ないんだから
もうマッチマッチ棒の状態でサッと消すと
そうやって我々何か間違いを犯したならば
まあすぐそこはもうちゃんと認めて
早く処理をする ごまかしごまかすとも
かなりかなり怯えて逃げることだから
その怯えが悪い怯えなんです
悪行為することを怯えることが正しい立派な臆病なんです
だから この懺悔の場合はすごいややこしくて
悪いものも良いものもありますからね
はい そういうことで はい
それでは  はいはい どうぞ
意見に貢献しようと自分が思った時に
自分がしていることが自己満足なのか
本当に自分でやっていたっていうのかを
やってる時に自分で判断とかするっていうことは
それで自分に疑問が湧いてきたりとかするんですが
その判断というのはどういうふうにしているのか
うん あのね 自分で判断して生きていられません
なぜなら我々は悟ってないし
全て知らないでしょ ですから
お釈迦様は 4つだよと教えてくれたんだから
貢献は 4つだよと 単にそれが論理的で具体的でわかりやすいでしょ
だからそれやればいいんです
自己満足であろうか どうでもいいです
そこは気にしなくても
一応自分がお釈迦様を 4つ項目を教えたんだから
それやってますよと 例えば役に立つことをアドバイスしたとしても
相手には役に立つアドバイスではなかったとかね
まあそれはしょうがないんですよ
私も結構アドバイスしますけど
ほとんど役に立ってないみたいです
だからそれはしょうがないんです
でもどうすればいいかと言われると
こちらがものすごく真剣に一生懸命これでこれでこれだと言ってはあげます
そういうわけで この自分でこれは傲慢ではないか
自己満足ではないかと思うことはよくないんですね
まあ我々のやり方は まあこれはお釈迦様に教えられたんだから
まあ実行しようと という自分の考え方を捨てちゃうんです
捨てて 智慧の完成者の教えに従うということで
そういうわけで 自分ではあまり気にしない方がいいと思います
これは自己満足かどうか
あれやこれやとかね まあそれはどうでもいいんだけど
やってることはいいんじゃないかっていうことでいいんです
私たちは人を批判する場合でも同じことでね
あの人はただ名誉のためにやってるんだけど
やっぱりそれもやってることはいいんだよと
まあ自分の国でも結構そういう人々はいますよ
自分の個人的な名誉のために
人気者になるために もういろんなことをやってますけど
私はすごくすごく批判しますけど
しかし 実際やってること何やというと
結構立派なことをやっているんです
それはそれはもう批判できなくなるんですね
ある人はこの幼稚園作ったんです
でっかくて すっごい贅沢で
自分の国でもないぐらい贅沢で作って
幼稚園に入れる子供たちは
医者の子供 弁護士の子供とか
一流の子供しか入れないんですね
まあそれで幼稚園は無料なんです
で 私はこの野郎 何やってるのかと
まあねと思ったんだけど
まあ逆に考えれば まあ立派な幼稚園ができてあって
まあ金持ちの子供たちがもうただで贅沢にいろいろ遊んで
なんとか成長して まあそれでもいいんじゃないかなと思ったりはする
こういうでいたいわ まあそこまで皆様悪くないんだから
あの あまり気にすることはないと思います
それから自己満足ということも一概に悪くないんですよ
これが逆に必要なんですよ
自分が役に立っているんだよと
この充実感という私は使う単語
それが必要ですよ 何やっても無駄だよと思っちゃうと
もう生きていられないでしょ
ですから あんまり自己満足とかね
もうあんまり別に嫌がらなくてもいいんです
自分がなんとか満足感を感じないとやりきれないんです
だからそれが悪いわけじゃないんです
ただ自分のエゴで満足だけか
考えちゃうとろくなことできなくなるだけのことで
その場合はブッダのアドバイスに従って行動する
決してこの充実感 まあ自分でもなかなか我ながら頑張っているんじゃないかというね
自己評価は決して悪くありません
これが自分を奮闘させるために必要なご褒美なんです
それに怖がらなくてもよろしいんです
人を笑わせたり 芸術とかということで人を楽しませる
ちょっと大きい声で  人を笑わせたり
芸事とかで人を楽しませるように
人の欲 怒り 愚痴など広がらないようにする
注意する これとまた違います
これにはすごい才能が必要なんですよ
芸術世界っていうのは欲と怒りと無知の世界なんですよ
でもたまたまありますよ
立派な作品というのはね
いわゆる人間を愛すること
いろいろ語っているとかね
そういう 芸術の場合は結構能力が必要なんです
だから仏教の人々も芸術家はいくらでもいますよ
仏教は芸術家を重要にします
と言ったっても もう仏教の世界っていうのはもうもうずっと踊りの世界なんで
結局は 自分の国でもね
まあ昔からみんなよく踊って歌って
もう踊り歌いが歌がない場所がないんです
田んぼであろうか 踊って歌い歌うは
もうどこででも 楽しく
お寺でもそうなんです
お寺の法事っていうのは日本の法事とずいぶん違います
何かもう踊りがあるんです
だからまあなんかおかしいんですけどね
逆にやっぱり 例えば歌がありますよ
歌の中身はすごい勉強になること
踊りでもそういう何か人の役に立つこと
何か表現しようとするんです
今日もちょこっとスリランカの伝統的な踊りの現代的なバージョンで一部見たんですけど
これ昔 この我々 このインド文化を受ける前のね
昔のね 原始時代の文化のつなげなんですけど
このもうこの悪魔祓いみたいな踊りがありまして
で あの 蛇の神様がいて
まあ蛇と言うんですね
コブラと で 神様じゃない
悪霊ですね まあそれがもう人間に不幸
病気をしたりする そうするとガルダのもう霊が来て
このガルダっていうのはこのもう鳥で
もうコブラを食べるんですね
だから実際見ると蛇を食べる鳥がいるんですね
それはもう心霊の話までもう進むだけの話で
それで今日踊り見てみると
なんかコソコソとこの蛇の悪霊が仮面かぶって舞台に入るんですね
あっち向いてこっち向いて
まああまり顔も見せないでいて
どんどんもう顔を見せたりして
もう踊ったり 我が物の感じで踊っていると
それであんまりにも踊りすぎになってくると
ゆっくりとガルナの仮面かぶってる人が美しく入るんですね
まあ鳥だからね 手も広げて美しく入って
それでお互いなんかもう戦いで踊るんですね
それでどうせあのガルダが悪霊を食べるんだからね
これで人間が幸福になるというイメージで
その時はもうすごく可愛かったのは
このガルダ まあ一応もう踊りでこの蛇を攻撃して
もう蛇の仮面かぶっている人はしゃがんでまた踊ってるんですね
そうすると向こうはあっち向いてこっち見て
なんかすごい心配そうな顔で
この仮面をそういうふうに感じるように仮面を振っちゃうんですよ
だからまあそれすごい可愛かったんですけどね
で それで連れていくんです
もうもう負けたところで
だからそこでこの悪を攻撃しても
むちゃくちゃ怒りで攻撃するんじゃなくて
まあこんなことで困りますからということで
いい加減やめろというね
でいて もう倒れた蛇に対しても
なんか心配そうに見ているというね
だから何か微妙に学ぶものっていうのは入ってるんですね
だからこの芸術はダメってことでもないんです
難しいんです それでも別れの歌は簡単ですよ
で 僕にとってはすごくつまらないんですよ
もう 30年ぐらいの歌
ずっと見て同じ歌なんですよ
あなたのことは世界一好きだよとかね
あなたがいなかったら生きていられませんよとか
何て歌をよく歌うこと
つまらないんじゃないかなと
で 自分の国ではそういう歌は大体まああるんですけど
ある一部のセクションのそういう歌を歌わない
今日も一つ歌を聞いてるんですけど
朝 その歌にあるのはスリランカの最近
バレンタインの習慣が強引にこの金持ちの連中が紹介をしているんですよ
それに対して歌なんですよ
どんな歌かというと 何やってるのかと
恋人にバレンタインデーがあったりして
母親に母の日があったりして
いい加減にしろよと バレンタイン
あなた戻って自分の国に戻ってくださいと
いらんと我々には 私たちの母親は 24時間
朝晩朝も晩も 365 日間我々のことを心配しているんだよと
ですから 我々には毎日母の日だよと
ですから あんたはどうぞお帰りなさいって歌なんです
で もう一流の歌手ですけどね
もうトップランクのね
だからもう歌唱力はトップランクで
歌もよろしいし 音楽もすごい
もう誰の真似でもない作品であるし
中身もなかなかなもので
バレンタインさん 自分のを家へ戻りということで
最後のフレーズで終わるんです
怒るんですね この歌手が
なんてことですかと 母の日があるということは
とんでもないことを持ってくるんじゃないんだよと
母は 365 日間頑張ってますよ
心配しているんだよと
そんな感じ だからいろいろ社会の問題とかね
扱って そこで歌一つ作って踊ったりするとかね
何か役に立つようにしようと頑張っているんです
文化的にはそれで結構売れます
日本ではやっぱりあなたを抱きしめたいと言わないと
なので私もそういう歌を見ていますけど
君に抱きしめたらすごい気持ち悪いでしょうと
歌も下手でしょうし とかね
もう歌唱力もあまりないし
それで決まってるパターンで振り付けを覚えながら
これ感じますからね 頭でこれ振り付けいろいろ覚えながらもやってるんだからね
やっぱり気持ち悪くなるでしょうとね
って思っちゃうんです
まあとにかく難しいことは難しいんですけど
できるだけ人の役に立つ
人に何かメッセージを伝える芸術であるならば素晴らしいと思います
それでは今後のことも
今後の思う 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
愛護の祈り 比丘の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の人々及けものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての人々が幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サッビーティヨー イワンジャントゥ サッバローゴー イナッサトゥ マテー パワットワンタラーヨー スキーディーナー ユコー バヴァ
バワトゥ サッバ マングララン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァター サッバ ブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッバ ダンマーヌバ
ーヴェーナ サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティー バワントゥテー
アビワーダナシー ヒッサ ニッチャン ワッダー パチャーイノー
チャッターロー ダンマ ワッダンティー アユワンノー スカンバラン
サーティ サーティ サーティ
では どうもありがとうございます
[鳥の鳴き声]